[Music]  the word education comes from a latin  word that means to lead  forth fourth is a value-laden term  it raises a question which way is fourth  how do you know you're going in the  right direction the easy answer in our  time  is it just depends on which way you want  to go young people  almost always say that today they've  been taught to say that  but that's the wrong answer  at hillsdale college we understand  education to be  the pursuit of the highest answer to  that question  discovering the right way by reading the  greatest books by the greatest minds in  history  coming to see the meaning of three  ultimate  and related things the good the true  and the beautiful this is the way forth  this is education